Hanscom breasts - today we're gonna do
another ten things you shouldn't goggle
I found some of the most discussed out
like honestly I we're just gonna do as
many as we can
got a list got a [__] list why am I
doing this cuz I'm a man and this is
what we do yeah
what starts with let's start with good
old cake farts quite a classic now I
assume we've all seen the cake farts
before am i right it's on pornhub okay
then yes that is a cake I said made out
of farts I don't know know what I like
the most
cakes cake farts how interesting out of
everything out of everything in the
whole world
she likes cake farts more than Jesus
okay she has a plan I like to be
comfortable when I eat cake - okay well
that's an interest she's gonna eat the
cake with her vagina oh no that's too
much don't do it ah ah make it strong
who came up with this idea don't [__]
yourself she's like no I'm done I'm
[__] done - Jesus Christ there you go
that was cake farts thank you thank you
very much for that okay well this one
should be nice no let's not look at that
toenail oh boy oh that looks oh oh dude
my man ah what do you mean ha ha ha
oh no that's not ear that's I want to
kill myself oh you don't say Meg uh
alright let's keep going
Teletubbies dot V foresee what the [__]
is this moving on one trip what is the
budget flag oh my god baby we'll get the
tripod what's wrong with you
[Music]
oh wait he's holding whoa uh oh it feels
like oh no it's not out is he moving
just if you feel resistance don't keep
pulling oh that is nasty
that is disgusting I quite like bellezza
what's that it I don't [__] them
[__] even [__] to understand
drainage of large abscess hole an area
containing accumulation of fish that's
quite big No
in the continuation of that video we are
going to drain this axis
oh I can't all right awesome
okay let's let's switch up to some nicer
stuff all right two guys one horse let's
do this the [__] am I looking at you oh
my god nope all right no don't want to
watch a guy getting [__] by a horse
just want that for the record all right
I'm not I didn't watch anything I didn't
see anything
no one saw any horse [__] egde okay do
not do not support that but moving on
Harlequin baby lights oh god what death
nope what is that I can't stop looking
away but I feel like I should a skin
disease often deadly which means your
skin grows 14 times quicker than normal
it's very rare oh the [__] happened what
is this
does it smell like it did last time with
the [__]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
ah my eyes my eyes Oh crying I can't do
more I could just [__] get it okay
for us I'm fine
ha leave a like if you enjoyed this
video and if you want to see part for it
that's it for me for now where's my
brofist always stay awesome right oh it
goes in the butthole the fish goes in
the bubble chicken upper planning
[Music]